heat is definitely coming well the
nevada legislator is considering a bill
to cap fees
charged by third party food delivery
apps like door dash or uber eats on
restaurants
8 news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the issues and what the bill
may change
regarding the platforms various
businesses in the las vegas valley
including tacoterian here in downtown
las vegas support this new bill
after having issues with third-party
food service providers it's going to
show the customer
that uh how how evil these guys are
carlos corralco owns the plant-based
mexican food restaurant
he says takeout orders increased by more
than 50 percent
since the start of the pandemic but
third-party providers by postmates
ubereats doordash and grubhub
take as much as 30 percent of each order
senate bill 320 would cap that at 20
percent
during the state of emergency critics
argue the bill may reduce food service
availability and
possibly make delivery more expensive
proponents say it can help restaurants
make up money
they have lost because of capacity
restrictions so the intent behind the
cap is that it's just for the remainder
of the emergency order
we don't intend to play or mess with
free market
after the pandemic the bill also
addresses billing transparency
third party platforms making commissions
public and
menu stealing restaurant owners say some
companies take their menus
and post it online without their consent
they will use a menu that is a year
two years old and you don't have those
items anymore so do
the restaurant look bad to the eyes of
the customer
restaurants in the valley are partnering
to launch their own food delivery
service
next month called local las vegas it's
owned by restaurants
for restaurants to compete with food
delivery service platforms
reporting in downtown las vegas kristen
drummond 8 news now
well clark county commissioners approved
an emergency ordinance in august
prohibiting a third party delivery
services from charging restaurants more
than 15 percent
of the online order price denise